je m'appelle année là mais ceci mon
premier reportage pour l'épicerie mon
sujet les aubergines ce fruit légume ne
fait pas l'unanimité son bar on aimerait
savoir si vous aimez les aubergines je
compte tellement porté vers les eaux
bref je l adore les aubergines moi pas
du tout le goût il est un peu amer la
texture est moche
impopulaire l'aubergine depuis une
dizaine d'années ce fruit gagne tout de
même en popularité à la ferme chez mario
on en cultive une grande variété sur un
terrain de plus en plus étendues il ya
l'amour là conventionnés qu'on connaît
beaucoup sinon madame blanche lazer bris
on a aussi la chinoise ce qu'on appelle
qui comme une longue bananes les
aubergines ne faisait pas partie des
projets initiaux de la ferme mais à la
demande de ses clients italiens libanais
du roumain le producteur s'est lancé
dans la culture de ce prix vous avec la
nationalité et qui en consomment le
moins c'est peut-être nous les lire les
québécois mais de plus en plus par
l'influencé des autres nationalités qui
ne transmettent der certes une ouverture
très grand sur l'auberge a tendance à
l'auberge et on imagine des recettes
comme la ratatouille la moussaka le
bagad auch mais c'est vraiment un frais
passe partout et on peut faire plein de
choses avec mon avis si quelqu'un n'aime
pas les aubergines sait pas vraiment qui
ils ont eu un des versions qu'il était
mal cuisiner ça prend beaucoup de
bien panier des aubergines les réserves
les marines et les sauver il ya plein de
possibilités
les plus petites aubergines sont ici
préparer en deux étapes on les paye plus
les immergent dans le gras les
pesticides c'est juste pas besoin à
fondre du tour ou chauffer un peu
d'huile et saint puy savage aux proches
aidants gars est également le pocher
dans l'eau tu veux pas les frais c'est
pas le but les amazones sur la grille
c'est pour faire du pirée on est trop
créé le point simple de détruire toute
la texture yo gabba les aubergines noir
plus courantes en épicerie se concocte
elle aussi très bien de cette façon on
se tourne maintenant vers l'aubergine
chinoise
qu'est-ce qu'on avait avec ses morceaux
là on fait un empire et puis faire
pocher leurs pensées faire sauter ça va
faire qu'on voit plusieurs préparations
sauter aucune qu'on a fait des gorges et
non des gorges et c'est vraiment plus
sain et à pour fixer la texture quand il
fait d'une marinade conserve que
d'autres choses pendant que les
aubergines chinoise au goût plus doux
sont transformés en accompagnement de
type salsa ou chet nez sur le gril les
aubergines sicilienne prennent des
couleurs
ça va juste comment faire griller on va
attendre que tout est brûlé mais tout
est bien coloré commence à voir des
bulles d'eau qui commencent à sortir
doit venir l'eau dans l'aubergine est en
train de bouillir
exact alors c'est comme légèrement gris
mais également cuillère ben c'est
tellement juteuse tellement bon steak tu
peux servir c'est juste comme ce super
facile à faire ça oui c'est un super
bonne véhicule pour n'importe quoi
d'autre que tu veux faire la tombe
abrite on va faire ça dans les prix pour
le moment blitz tous les couleurs grillé
[Musique]
après une quinzaine de minutes les
petites aubergines confites sont prêtes
à être ferme et juteuse comme des
tomates elles peuvent accompagner une
salade ou se manger tout seul garnier
qu'il
ya plein différents arrêtés après la
façon de créer un pont les manger
choisis ton préféré chaque nationalité
cuisine l'aubergine différemment ce qui
fait que ont réussi à passer toutes les
grosseurs d'aubergines puis ce qui est
favorable au plan d'eau vers j'aime
parce qu'ils ont réussi à vider un plan
d'aubergines peu importe la grosseur
l'aubergine produits de nouvelles fleurs
donc de nouveaux fruits
avec l'aubergine zébré le chef michele
for john et nous transporte dans le sud
de l'italie la belle côte amalfitaine
seller positano sorento lee burke a
appris il nous prépare une recette toute
spéciale de son enfance un plat festif à
base d'aubergines et de chocolat c'est
un dessert atypique du site de
l'italique pas beaucoup de monde
connaisse des fruits confits et des noix
une petite crème ou ricotta délit car
délicat de derb de safran de cannelle
qui apprécie vraiment fini avec une
sauce au chocolat mais ça surprend ses
domaines d aubergines et puis c'est ça
c'est dit et quand on est vraiment des
belles aubergines terme toujours faire
un si brillant c'est ainsi que
l'aubergine est vraiment fraîches seimat
c'est pas vrai les aubergines doivent
être coupés en tranches fines qui sinon
s'isolait l'aubergine c'est comme une
éponge vous ça va être trop milieu on va
aller dans la farine puis après dans de
l'oeuf et après il se montre encline aux
ça va donner une belle croûte
le premier étage aubergines imbibé avec
l'astra gars qui après la ricotta
helicopters subsiste strong chocolat et
canal puis de continuer à les offrir
c'est fou hein c'est un dessert à
l'aubergine on connaît pas sa méfiance
j'affine à faire avec les enfants exo
strega qui est très parfumée bravo
donc ton plat dans le frigo qui après la
fin des fins comme la de trois minutes à
28 mais la sauce au chocolat parce que
tu veux vraiment que tout les
ingrédients s'imbibe
trois mariages mais sept maris donc
prochaine étape et jc cendres du
chocolat 70% mi amer pour un petit peu
d'amertume puis après je rajoute la
noisette pu regarder c'est tout haut
et
voilà
bon appétit et en gras 6000
j'espère en fait ça à la maison
[Musique]